[Music]
[Applause]
pat 40 the voice of college football he
covers it for sports illustrated he was
at the national title game still in
indianapolis well what did you make of
last night's festivities pat
uh cathartic night for the bulldogs and
their fans waiting 41 years to win a
title and having to go through their
nemesis to do it and
looking like
stetson bennett maybe gave the game away
on that flute play and then they just
they rally after that and dominate the
rest of the game uh and i thought they
were the best team all season
and they proved it when they had to so
it was a good game uh you know i think
that uh you know it was competitive
it's always interesting i think to see
somebody challenge alabama like that and
uh i enjoyed the evening how would the
season have been different if we had a
12-team playoff or would it have been
different
um we would have had a much more
interesting postseason first of all you
would have had people like kenny pickett
and kenneth walker the third play their
bowl games or their their playoff games
because they would have been in
you would have had campus games
uh that were part of the playoff
so all that would have been good and
then the final result still would have
been georgia and alabama beating the
snot out of everybody and then beating
the snot out of each other in the
championship game what's the holdup
right now for the expansion with the
playoffs
uh the hold up is posturing ego
uh maneuvering it the acc is a hold up
uh the big 10 to a degree is a hold up
the pac-12
is still trying to prop up the rose bowl
uh the reasons why don't make sense to
me i you know these guys are getting
paid a lot of money to figure this stuff
out and they're not doing it that was
one of the things a couple of things
that came out of it dan yesterday is one
some of the commissioners are definitely
losing patience with this i mean bob
bullsby the big 12 came out just blowing
up everybody
but then the presidents uh of these
schools that are you know
running the the playoff management
committee
are fed up with the commissioners too
and basically told them we'll we'll get
this done if you guys can so i think
that we're kind of reaching a point
where things have to happen
help me understand this this is the
first paragraph on espn.com the leaders
of the college football playoff
uh again failed to come up with an
agreement about expanding the current 14
field but they didn't entirely rule out
the possibility it could still happen
before the end of the current 12-year
contract which runs through 2025.
when i reported this a little while ago
pat i got beat up by you college
football insiders
that they were trying to speed this up
they they from somebody who's involved
in this said they were looking at 2023.
uh is there a chance that we're going to
have this done and i was you know i had
the insiders saying hey there's a
contract don't you understand the
contract and i thought money breaks
contracts here kids uh is there a chance
that this might not have to wait until
2025.
money always breaks contracts you are
correct and it could be i mean it could
be that there's this brinksmanship going
on of like we're not budging we're not
budging we're not budging until the last
possibility then okay we'll budge um
it's not out of the question because as
you said they are leaving
scads of money on the table if you don't
break the contract and and renegotiate
this and expand the thing so
the tendency or the the
instinct of these people is to always go
for more money so yes i think there's a
chance that they can still do this
jim harbaugh to the nfl
uh or a pay raise
well i know this we sure haven't heard a
single word from anybody in ann arbor
tamping down any uh talk about him in
the nfl uh nobody has stepped up to say
no there's nothing to it jim's happy to
be here he's going to stay a long time
a couple of schools of thought there yes
one is this just is this negotiation and
leverage or
uh
the other school and some of the stuff
that i heard in south florida when i was
there for the orange bowl was that he
was legitimately like offended by the
pay cut that he took after last year and
he does
enjoy the nfl and would be happy to go
back that he kind of got his job done
in terms of resurrecting michigan
he hasn't been a long-term one place guy
i think he tends to wear himself out and
wear the people out around him
and this timing might be right right now
yeah that's what i was told and you know
i know that steven ross said the owner
of the dolphins hey i don't want to take
him away from my alma mater but if you
know that jim harbaugh
might want to go and maybe the raiders
then stephen ross can say well he does
want you're not taking him away from his
alma mater he's he's leaving his alma
mater and then maybe the dolphins are in
the mix here but i know there were
reporters who refuted that yesterday um
the impact on dia with dion sanders on
college football is what
uh it's pretty electrifying you know i
mean this guy who did a lot of
electrifying things as a player and he
is right now as a coach i mean
for
jackson state to be getting some of the
players they have gotten is is a
absolute game changer uh eye-opener for
everybody who said
you know the power in college football
will always be collected in the hands of
a few
maybe not you know that if you can get a
guy like him who can go in and i think
obviously they are prepared to offer
major nil uh
uh packages to people and that helps too
that but is nil
can be a playing field leveler in my
opinion dan not you know it's something
that just helps georgia alabama clemson
ohio state but there's there's a lot of
places that like football there's a lot
of fans and boosters that like football
they're like hey we can we can pay a guy
here too and you're going to have
players that are going to listen to that
but i wonder if
like i'm surprised that florida state
didn't offer him the job now they might
have looked at him and said you know
this is a lot bigger and it's you know
you got to be a ceo and all of that
uh dion is never embarrassed like he
he's a prideful guy and he doesn't get
embarrassed very often and it feels like
you know these recruits bought into i'm
playing for dion sanders
if i'm a university i got an opening
i reach out to dion because those two
players are going to follow dion sanders
sure no i you know what next next hiring
cycle somebody's hiring him uh unless he
wants to stay at jackson state which
isn't out of the question but you know
he he
got involved to a degree at the tcu job
search colorado state and didn't get
either of those but
now you start getting real talent and
that talks you know and yes somebody is
going to hire him he does he has that
personality he has that ability to
to just kind of uh you know bring people
to him and bring attention to him and
his program
seems to be a pretty good coach 11 and 2
i believe his first year there lost to
their bowl game but still you know that
he's done an awful lot more than i think
people underestimated him i think as a
coach and he's made an instant impact
pat 40 sports illustrated senior writer
joining us from indianapolis this whole
name image and likeness fallout is
interesting charlie batch
not even the coach at eastern michigan
says hey
caleb williams i'll give you we'll give
you a million dollars to play for
eastern michigan now caleb williams may
be headed to usc but
it it feels like
college football is the wild wild west
and there's nobody really governing
you know what you can make can they put
a cap on this like where are we headed
with name image and likeness here
i don't know
it's crazy
yes the
the here's this is classic ncaa
situation where
okay we're going to make this rule
change we have no idea what the
unintended consequences are we have no
idea what the side effects are oh geez
there's a lot of them how do we get the
horse back in the barn the horse is
running all over the pasture now i don't
know how you get the horse back in the
barn but there's going to be an
incidental convention next week and
those are some of the questions
what are the rules now and how are they
enforced and and
what can you do and not do and i'm
pretty sure
according to the rules like what charlie
batch did is definitely a violation you
know you can't just say hey if you come
here we'll give you a million dollars
now
that's really probably what's happening
behind the scenes but i i don't think
you advertise that as a recruiting
incentive because that would then fall
under
pay for play which the ncaa says they
still don't want to do but i mean this
whole thing has just spun so far i think
beyond where everybody thought it may be
going bryce young makes more at alabama
than jalen hurts does in the nfl
that's awesome about 500 dollars i think
hertz makes eight hundred thousand and
uh bryce i was told made 1.3 million in
alabama this past year yeah you know i
mean like he's got deals there he he has
a podcast which it's pretty funny i
actually listened to it a couple of
times getting ready for this game where
bryce says like 20 words in the podcast
you know he's got a host who does the
work and they bring out a guest who does
the talking and bryce kind of sits in
the middle says hey thanks for coming on
[Laughter]
pretty good gig
is caleb williams going to usc
certainly seems that way with jackson
dart leaving as well all of usc's
quarterbacks have have cleared out uh
the the starting job is there for him to
take lincoln riley is there with him
uh
they may take uh excellent freshman wide
receiver from oklahoma's in the transfer
portal as well mario williams and all of
a sudden you know i think usc reboots in
a hurry and gets a lot better
safe travels back pat great to talk to
you again buddy
all right thank you dan appreciate it
that's pat forty sports illustrated
senior writer and look i'm a big boy i
can take the heat got roughed up by
quite a few college insiders that i had
the audacity to say
that maybe they're going to get this
college playoff
kicked off before 2025.
i i you know they i had people say wait
you they have a they have contracts you
can't break contracts i go
if you only knew my source then you
wouldn't be saying this
because contracts are meant to be broken
because of money